the North remembers we know no king but
the king in the north whose name is
stark
I don't care if he's a bastard that
starts blood runs through his veins
he's my king from this day until his
last day sword for the wall you already
have a good man have you swung it yet
of course it up at someone I mean
strange thing first time you cut him out
realize we're nothing but sacks of meat
blood and some bone to keep it all
standing what's up ladies and gentlemen
welcome back for another Game of Thrones
season a prediction video today I want
to talk about the Kingslayer
Sir Jaime [ __ ] Lannister I'm assuming
all of you are up to date with where
this character is currently at in the
story but I will briefly add a little
context to what I want to say one of
Jamie's last scenes was in the season 7
finale where we see him planning to take
the Lannister men north to help Jonathan
Aerys fight the army of the dead
during the meeting in the dragon pit
Cersei eventually agrees to help by
sending all of her banners north so
Jaime was making plans to do just that
he was still under the impression that
they were going to help but Cersei had
her own ulterior motives
Cersei wanted the army of the Dead to
invade the north because she is hoping
they can take out her enemies for her
she also has Euron going to Essos to
pick up 20,000 mercenaries from the
golden company just in case Jaime was
obviously very upset with Cersei when
she revealed her true intentions because
he knows if the army of the dead when
they're gonna come south and kill them -
and if John and Daenerys win they will
come and kill them for not helping he
knows they are pretty much screwed
unless they try and do the right thing
by helping Plus I think deep down Jaime
wants to help anyway he has been on a
very long road to redemption and the
only thing that has been holding him
back from fully committing to his good
side is Cersei in my opinion up until
this point Cersei has been the main
influence over what decisions Jaime
ultimately makes now that Jaime has left
Cersei I am confident he will live up to
his end of the agreement
even if Jaime has to travel alone
all the way to Winterfell I think he
wills so that he can help them defeat
the army of the dead now there is a very
good chance Jamie could run into some
trouble when his way north because
almost everyone hates the Lannisters but
before he left King's Landing he did
change out of his Lannister colors and
he also hid his golden hand so he might
be able to make it there without being
captured or killed as long as Jaime can
make it to Brienne or Tyrion I think he
will be just fine
even though Jaime did try to kill brain
stark back in the first season I think
they will ultimately accept Jaime's help
I kind of have this feeling brain is
going to see his injury as his destiny
something that had to happen in order
for him to become the new three-eyed
Raven as long as brain is okay with
having Jaime around then I think
everyone else will pretty much have to
accept it for the time being as much as
everyone might hate Jaime right now they
do need his help to win the great war
but the only problem is Jaime's no
longer the swordsman he once was I can
hold her sword Oh mind things are wrong
not long ago
Jaime was arguably the greatest
swordsman alive but with only one hand
he can barely defend himself against a
stableboy
the last time Jaime entered a battle his
life had to be saved on two separate
occasions or else he would have died and
now that he's about to volunteer to help
out in the Great War I think we're gonna
see him get saved again Jaime may have a
Valyrian steel sword but he is still a
show of his former self
the next time Jaime steps on the
battlefield we will see someone or
something try and kill him and right as
they're about to deliver the fatal blow
someone will save Jaime again I truly
believe there is going to come a point
where we see Jon Snow save Jaime's life
and have a pretty good reason for why I
think this will happen there is a scene
from season 1 episode 2 that led me to
believe this could happen the way
everything has played out since then
makes me think Jaime will be put in this
let's take a look at the scene I am
referring to this is when Jamie and John
meet for the first time and it's not a
very pleasant experience for John we've
got the kingdom's for 8,000 years we
already have you taken your vows then
soon enough give my regards to the
Nights Watch I'm sure it will be
thrilling to serve in such an elite
force and if not it's not only for life
as you can see the first time these two
characters met Jamie did his best to
Punk Jon out by treating him like a
[ __ ]
Jamie had zero respect for the Nights
Watch and what they stood for you have
to remember at that time Jamie was a
member of the Kingsguard he probably
thought he was in the knight in shining
armor he was handsome he was rich he
came from a very powerful family and he
was arguably the best swordsman in all
of Westeros at that time he was
basically a celebrity even with his
tarnished reputation then in Jamie's
eyes here was the boy named Jon Snow
he was just another bastard that meant
nothing to Jamie and who would probably
never amount to anything
the Nights Watch was seen as a joke at
that time also the wall was being
guarded by nothing but a bunch of
thieves and rapists is no longer made up
of men of honor that were actually
protecting the realm from a serious
threat back then no one believed in the
threat of the White Walkers it was just
seen as another story to children to try
and scare them Jamie saw the Nights
Watch as just a bunch of misfit losers
that weren't actually protecting anyone
from anything other than maybe a few
wildling attacks here and there but boy
oh boy was Jamie wrong and look how the
tables have turned
Jamie is now the Birkin man who can no
longer protect anyone and Jon now has a
significant amount of power and ability
to hold his own in a sword fight against
just about anyone he faces also now he
knows the threat beyond the wall is real
and he got his first glimpse of this
during the meeting at the dragon pit
when Jon presented the white
when Jamie laid his eyes on this white
you could see that he was terrified and
that was only one of them wait until he
sees a hundred thousand whites being led
by white walkers in the night King I
think Jamie is going to regret the way
he spoke to John about the Nights Watch
he now knows just how important the wall
and the men who protected it were when
Jamie met John before he left for the
Nights Watch he was not expecting him to
be able to protect them from anything he
was even making fun of John for the fact
that he hadn't even killed a man yet but
now Jamie can't even defend himself and
John is one of the best swordsman let me
thank you ahead of time guarding us all
from the perils beyond the wall
wildlings and White Walkers and whatnot
a great good strong men like you
protecting us we've got it the kingdom's
for 8,000 years we already I think it
would be very interesting if John ended
up saving Jimmy's life during this war
against the night King it could tie into
this scene all the way back in season
one when they met for the first time
back then Jamie did not believe John
could fight nor did he believe the White
Walkers were even real and he had no
respect or love for the Nights Watch I
think it would be a nice slap in the
face for Jamie if he had to depend on
John or even some random man from the
Nights Watch to save him from being
killed eastwatch-by-the-sea might have
been destroyed by the night king but
there are still many Castle black and
the shadow tower all the remaining men
of the Nights Watch should be teaming up
with John very soon since there is
nothing left beyond the wall for them to
need to stay guarding the wall there
aren't too many men of the Nights Watch
left but they will be needed to come
help in the war given how Jamie was
making fun of John in the Nights Watch I
think it would be kind of poetic if he
needed to be saved by some random man
from the Nights Watch but obviously I
would prefer if John were the one to
save him since Jamie tried to make him
look like a joke right to his face I
still believe that Jamie will ultimately
sacrifice him
for one of the Starks in the end but
this would give him even more motivation
to do something like that if John put
himself in danger to save or help Jamie
in battle ever since the first episode
ended with Jamie pushing bran out of the
window I always felt like the end of his
character arc would be intertwined with
one of the Starks somehow Jamie is on
the road to redemption and I think there
could come a point where Jamie saves
brain in some way since he tried to kill
Brian but before that happens I think it
would be cool if Jamie was saved by John
or someone from the Nights Watch it
would be a great callback to one of
Jamie and John's first scenes in this
series let me know what you think would
you like to see something like this or
do you have something else in mind put
your comments down below anyways I want
to thank everyone for watching today's
video I really appreciate that and I
also want to thank my patreon supporters
have a great day
I'll see you again very soon bye
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]